bonjour vous venez pour le casting donc
allez-y rentrée une production
américaine recherche plusieurs centaines
de figurants âgés de 18 à 75 ans
objectif incarner des nobles des paysans
des soldats des serviteurs ou bien
encore des religieux dans une série
télévisée serpente queen sur la vie de
catherine de médicis 86 les blésois sont
venus nombreux se prêter au jeu de la
sélection et tenter leur chance
puisqu'on n'est pas du tout ce milieu là
donc je me suis dit voilà il ya un
casting sur bloch travail à côté c'était
c'était l'occasion et puis de tenter
quelque chose de jamais tenté c'est par
intérêt par des couleurs par amusement
voilà c'est pas pour l'argent c'est la
première fois que je fais ça en plus
et je pense que c'est vraiment le fait
que ce soit dans notre région et que ça
montre les paysages que ce soit dans
l'ancien temps tout ça ça fait découvrir
beaucoup de choses et
je trouve ça intéressant ça peut être
que du bonus d'essayer et puis il ya
ceux plus habitué à ce genre d'exercice
j'ai déjà participé une figuration dans
un film de luc besson
jeanne d'arc a été tourné ici au château
de blois
j'aime bien figurer dans des temps des
séries quelle que soit l'époque dans
l'histoire c'est de se faire kiffer
jeunes aux niveaux série avec avec les
costumes l'ambiance de l'époque elle
c'est de vivre un peu comme comme à
l'époque la situation
c'est un gros kiff et comme l'action se
déroule au 16e siècle
les critères de sélection sont bien
particulier nous privilégions les
cheveux longs que ce soit pour les
hommes ou des femmes en sachant que pour
les hommes
évitant à tout prix les coupes modernes
à savoir rasé sur les côtés pas de
couleur de cheveux
pas de mèche pas de franches pour les
femmes une fois sélectionner les
figurants auront droit à une séance
d'essayage de leurs costumes avant
d'entrer dans le rôle tournage prévu en
septembre au château de chambord et dans
la région